the interactions aren't classical but
the properties are okay
i'm glad that we can be so choosy about
how we're doing this this is wonderful
[Music]
this episode was made possible by
generous supporters on patreon
something that's very important to keep
in mind as we move forward right
that quantum mechanics sort of
brings to light a discrepancy in how
people view
physics sure we like to view physics
as though we're finding some deeper
understanding about the universe
but it's not really what physics is
about physics is about making
predictions
okay right we want to be able to science
is about making predictions
right well exactly so this what we try
to do in physics is we try to come up
with a model
that's going to predict future behaviors
of things
right so in this case quantum mechanics
is
predicting future behaviors of quantums
or
you know little quantum particles right
okay it allows us to make
accurate predictions correct using this
branch of science right but
this video this video is about what we
call
interpretations of quantum mechanics
okay so
even though this model is very good at
making predictions and everyone agrees
that that's true
many of us still want it to also
give us a deeper understanding of
physics and of the universe
the problem is there are a lot of
possible ways to interpret it
that haven't been ruled out by
experiment yet i'm sure that
that's difficult it is it's very
difficult cutting edge science
you know and i guess just uh just to be
clear this video is not a comprehensive
list
of interpretations of quantum mechanics
it is just
we're just covering a few examples to
get an idea of why
it's so difficult to do this one cannot
cover everything
right
one of the first major interpretations
is called the copenhagen interpretation
and don't don't get on my case about
this
i'm just talking about history here
i know there's a lot of are we feeling a
little defensive here
all right there are a lot of a lot of
copenhagen interpretation haters out
there
okay you're not condoning it you're just
stating that this is an interpretation
that exists
right but first we're going to start
with there's actually like two different
kinds
there's something we call the weak
copenhagen interpretation
and the strong copenhagen interpretation
and i assume that this does not actually
have to do with like how
scientifically like verbose they are
no it has to do with how strongly it
speaks about the nature of the universe
okay so the original one the one that
they
i think it was heisenberg in 1929
talked about this interpretation and
this one is the weak interpretation
okay we're basically it's called weak
because it doesn't
really interpret anything it takes the
stance that you were saying earlier
where well maybe it doesn't actually say
anything about the universe it's just a
really good model that makes great
predictions
sure and if it's a good model that makes
great predictions i mean
it doesn't it's not useless you know
what i mean right
that was uh a pretty decent place to be
it's it's summarized in
one one statement that a lot of quantum
physics teachers like to use
shut up and calculate oh sure i've heard
this before yeah okay i'm sure i've said
it before
i'm sure that's where i've heard it
before right that's sort of the idea
like stop trying to read into any of any
of this stuff just shut up
calculate the prediction and move on
with your life i mean i have to be
honest
if i was a physicist this would be
appealing to me
that's very much my personality type
right it takes the philosophy out of it
it does uh it's a very experimental
approach as a theoretical physicist
uh i can't stand for that so we're gonna
try and take some
more uh we're gonna take some stronger
approaches to this
all right so next up the strong
copenhagen interpretation which is
something that's developed over the last
you know the several decades after
heisenberg gave this talk which was in
29
29 yeah it takes it one step further and
says
not only does this wave function for an
electron describe
the electrons behavior
once it's used to calculate something
the wave function
before the collapse is also something
that physically exists
it is at a thing that is real and says
something about the universe
okay about that electron that we're
trying to examine okay
so the weak one says this isn't actually
real
it's just math that helps us predict
things right
and the strong one says it is math and
it does help us predict things and
also it's real right okay right that the
wave function is a very real thing
and that is literally how the electron
exists
before it collapses into one of these
regular states so
for the weak one what do they think the
electron
exists as if not the wave function they
don't
they don't think electrons exist it is a
very agnostic
approach to quantum mechanics we're not
going to make any judgments
at all i see about the electron i see i
feel like
that's not useful or helpful
because the electron does exist though
right
so somehow the point because it
like i said it's a very experimental
approach so it's very useful
in just setting your preconceived
notions aside making the calculations
maybe building something like a
transistor which is the foundation of
all modern electronics
i find it so interesting that this ends
up being
i mean we're not going to make any
judgments about electrons
but also we're going to go ahead and
make an
actual thing that utilizes electrons i
feel like these two things
don't don't go together as you can
imagine like i mean none of these
interpretations we're going to be
talking about today would exist if
people were satisfied with that
okay fair enough it was just uh let's
just put this aside and move on but then
you know people would come up and be
like hold on a second we need
all types right okay all right right
one of the things that we're going to
find as we go through today is that
all interpretations of quantum mechanics
have a problem
different problems diff different
problems for example the strong
copenhagen interpretation that says
electrons
exist as this superposition the major
problem that that has
is something we call determinism that
things are planned out ahead of time
right
things are not random the universe is
not
random then everything is determined
right
right it takes things like free will out
of the picture right
there are a lot of physicists out there
that have a really huge problem with
quantum mechanics being
non-deterministic
and so this idea this strong copenhagen
interpretation that that these particles
are inherently probabilistic
is a problem for people but it because
it violates determinism
it says that the universe is not
deterministic we'll hate to be the
bearer of bad news
but if the science says that
it's not deterministic it's
probabilistic then like
update yourselves that's my opinion on
that quantum physicists have tried to
come up with
a way for quantum mechanics to be
deterministic
okay they've tried to force it i was
going to say let's squeeze it into the
box
the problem with a lot of these
different interpretations is that when
you you
come up with a way to interpret quantum
mechanics so that it fixes one problem
it creates a different one
sure believable also i would just like
to say that i am
innately against doing science
with a particular goal in mind that's
not how science is done
you're not doing good science so i'm
i'm going into this interpretation
judging it
what ends up getting sacrificed when you
force determinism
onto quantum mechanics is something we
call
causality okay the order of cause and
effect
the best ways i've found to define each
of these things determinism and
causality is that determinism is
that the universe is is not random
probabilities
are only zero or one zero or a hundred
percent
okay there is no fifty percent chance of
anything it either is going to happen or
it isn't going to happen
that's determinism okay causality
is like i said it's the the order of
cause and effect
it's that causes in the past lead to
effects or events in the future the idea
that if we knew
everything about all of the particles in
the universe right now
we could predict the entire history
past and future and so this new
interpretation
doesn't abide by that right
in order to get determinism back into
quantum mechanics we have to sacrifice
causality usually okay there
is an entire category of interpretations
of quantum mechanics called
retrocausality not only
can effects travel into the future from
the past they can also travel into the
past from the future
wonderful they can retro retroactively
cause something
so retro causality right so that's the
that's the idea okay why how tell me how
we came to this conclusion
uh i mean it's not really a conclusion
it's just a guess
tell me how we came to this guess all
right so
there's one example it's called the uh
the transactional interpretation where
basically
a particle like an electron creates and
it has a wave function associated with
it right
okay and so what ends up happening is
this
wave function which it is affected by
wave functions traveling from the past
right some other particle in the past
its wave function moves forward into the
future and it affects this electron
sure that makes sense right
now the idea is that particles
complete wave function is a past and
future wave function
so not only are things sending
information into the future to affect
particles and events in the future
they're also sending
wave function another half of their wave
function into the past
to affect events in the past are all
events
affected by each wave function that is
produced
it can get rather complicated if your
system isn't isolated but that's true of
anything
in quantum mechanics isolated systems
don't exist right
unless you're talking about the universe
right right
right so technically it's not possible
but
we get close enough that these effects
start to show up not the retro causality
effects but
probably probability quantum mechanics
stuff
all right so the idea is that when you
have you take a measurement in the
future
the particles involved in that
experiment that measurement
can travel back in time and change the
behavior of the particle you measured
so anyway the point is retrocausality
yes
fixes the determinism problem right so
we can look back and we can say oh well
these two entangled particles they had
they had stuff you know they they were
they were predetermined to do what they
were going to do
but like it's only because there are
signals traveling forward and backward
in time and because the experiment
sent information back in time to affect
the particles
to make them do certain things because
they know that you did the experiment in
the future because retro causality
okay that's complicated i think that you
all should know that i hate time travel
uh innately in movies or whatever
it always is so complicated right so
i am not inclined to jump on board with
this one
uh and if you've seen any of my videos
you know that
i don't think time travel is possible so
i'm sure you can guess how i feel about
retro causality
okay so retro causality is something
that fixes determinism some of the time
right but quantum entanglement also
brings up another problem
okay
we have two other issues that come into
play
not just determinism and causality but
also something we call
locality and realism locality and
realism right okay locality
is essentially that a particle can only
be influenced by things
adjacent to its location right next to
it well so that would
innately disagree with the quantum
entanglement thing that we just talked
about right so that's that's a problem
that quantum entanglement
we need to address okay essentially
locality means that the speed of light
limit is maintained
in all circumstances okay things cannot
travel faster than light
now realism is that particles always
have single classical properties they
behave
just like billiard balls okay it's just
that we don't
understand what's happening enough but
they do
exist classically they exist classically
but we don't understand
how they work right i feel like that's
an oxymoron that will make sense
as we cover some of these next couple of
interpretations
okay but in 1965
there's this guy named john stewart bell
he came up with
and designed an experiment that proves
without a doubt that locality and
realism
cannot happen at the same time it is
physically impossible
it either follows classical mechanics or
it has classical properties
or it interacts with local particles
right but not at the same time right
and so what we say is that local realism
not a thing now you can have non-local
realism
where particles interact over vast
distances violating the speed of light
limit
but are real and have real properties or
can you be
real and have real properties while
violating the speed of light
apparently some people think so i feel
like that doesn't make sense
so that's one option the other option
is that you have non-real locality the
speed of light limit is maintained
but these particles don't have
properties before you measure them i
think
that's my favorite one that seems to
make the most sense to me
okay that one happens to be a at least
the example we're going to talk about
that does
that is going to be the one that is is
gaining a lot of popularity lately
so let's start with the one that
violates locality
okay that lets particles interact over
any distance instantaneously
but classically but exist with actual
properties
okay the interactions aren't classical
but the properties are okay
i'm glad that we can be so choosy about
how we're doing this this is wonderful
so this first one is something called
the pilot wave
model pilot as in like a pilot or pilot
as in like the first one
pilot is in like a pilot okay the idea
is that
the waves that are described in quantum
mechanics
aren't the actual particles they're just
these waves that exist
in the space in some other something
that we don't understand
we said we're doing non-local realism
right now right yes
okay yes the idea is that there's some
kind of
substance that we don't understand not
an actual like substance but
okay there is something that fills the
universe
that has waves in it and those waves
guide the particles and so they only
look like they behave randomly because
there's this very complex wave stuff
happening underneath them
on the quantum level right and so these
little tiny itty-bitty quantum waves
if you were to imagine some kind of like
little i don't know like a little
styrofoam ball floating on the surface
of
a tank of water and then you put waves
in the water the particle's gonna do all
sorts of weird stuff
right right because this wave is
affecting it a wave that we can't see
sure and quantum mechanics describes
describes the wave
in that stuff okay it doesn't describe
the actual particles i am
what disinclined to or whatever i don't
like it i i know it sounds completely
ridiculous
it does but i feel like we're not
following occam's razor at this point
right i don't think we are with the
other one either but we'll get to that
in a minute oh no
okay so the idea there is that the
particles
are like billiard balls they have
properties they do exist in the way that
we understand particles to exist they're
just affected by this complex like
undercurrent they are not the wave but
there are waves and they affect them
yes okay and whatever this stuff is
that's waving
can violate the speed of light limit
even though the particles themselves
can't this is very complex
yes now this does address the quantum
entanglement problem because
if this substance can yes and i say that
with sarcasm in my voice
this substance communicates faster than
light then
it's okay for one particle to
immediately collapse the wave function
of the other particle because these
waves are happening in this like
under material sure this under substance
that's controlling the quantum world
it's the under substance right i'm
i'm making it sound like science fiction
uh but like
it's pretty it's pretty close i mean
think about it
yeah i mean technically it's all science
fiction until it's experimentally
validated
right right
so this one is called the many worlds
interpretation
oh here we are here we are heard of that
one before
uh i think a lot of people would have
been very disappointed if i didn't talk
about this today well let's do it then
the idea with the many worlds model
interpretation i should say
is that there are an infinite number of
universes
and there is essentially one
wave function that describes the entire
multiverse
okay a very complex wave function and
as certain interactions take place and
measurements happen
the wave functions the sort of subway
functions of each individual universe
become unentangled
or they start in this sort of entangled
state where they're all
related to each other and then once
measurements are made once it becomes
known
to the universe not necessarily to a
person once it becomes known
what kind of state the particle is in
the universe kind of
splits it sounds like you're saying that
all of these waves that there are enough
waves for like all of the splitting that
it's eventually going to be doing like
all of those waves exist yes
but that would also sound pretty
deterministic though
yes yes because it has to you already
have to have that wave existing
in order for it to split yes right
right and so that's this is a major
a major reason that this
model this interpretation is so popular
it's because
it's only problem is realism okay
it is deterministic it's causal and it's
local
it just isn't real it's not real
right no big deal this is fine we're
fine
okay so so the idea is that these
universes split apart now it doesn't
mean that an entire
universe is created at the measurement
it's often described like that and
that's completely ridiculous
that's not what's happening we're saying
that is the ridiculous thing here
glad we ironed that out we're gonna draw
the line
the idea is that all these universes
already exist
it's just that they become unentangled
and separate from each other
they existed before they were just
entangled and now they're not
okay when that information becomes known
to the universe about these particles
they become separated in the multiverse
the quantum multiverse
this is wild yes i just feel like when
you're talking about
particles the number of universes that
we're talking about
is absurd right i mean particles and
events with those particles
right i mean because you're not even
talking about people doing something you
know what i mean you're talking about
particles
doing something and there's there's so
many so many
it's an unimaginable number of universes
that's what i'm trying to say
right but it's not real so it's okay
well
we're saying that the particles aren't
particles i know
it's funny to say that it's not real but
that's not really what realism is saying
so that's the idea right that the the
universe is you can map them across
time so it's causal the probability of
something an event happening in the
multiverse somewhere
is equal to one or one hundred percent
you just might not be in the universe
where it happens but it does happen
so it is deterministic and so if there's
a
50 50 chance in quantum mechanics that
says oh well
this event is going to happen or it's
not going to happen like a radioactive
decay of a particle or something
what the many worlds interpretation says
is well
that does happen in half the universe is
and it doesn't in the other half
sure but it happens somewhere right if
there's a chance if there's a non-zero
chance it's going to happen it happens
somewhere in the multiverse right
i mean which is kind of comforting on
one side
sure and uh concerning on the other side
right
but the effects are local right so
there's localities maintained because
the interaction happens locally
right it doesn't happen over vast
distances this is okay
with quantum entanglement because
everything's deterministic and causal
the
the particle on earth and the particle
on mars don't have to communicate with
each other they were already
predetermined to be the way they were
we just didn't know about it i don't
love that determinism
isn't my favorite thing well because it
doesn't allow for free will
and i i have a problem with that sure
which is why
i am very very firmly
under the non-deterministic umbrella
yeah whatever
interpretation i get behind it better be
non-deterministic
or i'm not getting behind it sure the
hardcore physicists are starting to
get really get behind this mini world's
interpretation but not the
softcore physicist definitely not me
when i was starting to like really dive
into this and learn about it i
i can understand why it's so appealing
to people
it solves so many problems but it does
it in a way
that i feel violates the
most important tenet of coming up with a
model and that is occam's razor right
agree we have to assume a a
an infinite or nearly infinite number of
universes exist
even though we have no physical evidence
whatsoever that they exist
right that cannot be
the like least complicated
answer right occam's razor does not
say that explanations can't be
complicated it just says that we need to
start with the simpler ones
right and if we rule them all out and we
arrive at something that's complicated
then so be it
uh that's how quantum mechanics happened
but
i think that i think there are better
options i think it's good to have
many hypotheses right yes because it's
it's good to be able to
like get a new idea and assess it see
how it works
see how it doesn't work and then when
you see that like there are x y and z
reasons why this doesn't appear to be
the one
let's move on to the next one you know
what i mean i think that it's not good
science to get caught on one hypothesis
and just keep beating it to death trying
to make it work for you
and i'm not talking about the many
worlds specifically i mean for any of
them in general
something we expect out of scientists in
general right if you're gonna oppose if
you're going to
propose an alternative explanation for
something
you better also at the same time propose
a way to test it
yeah or else what good is it what good
is
is a proposed explanation without an
experiment that you can do to test it
right agree and i acknowledge that our
whole conversation today existed
because we just don't have the
experimental means
to test these right hypotheses but
that means that they do need to be
treated as such though right i think
that's the biggest problem with the many
worlds interpretation is that it's
it is completely untestable right there
is literally no experiment you can come
up with
that allows us to test whether or not
other universes exist
at least as far as we know as right now
right
i'm not discounting it in the future but
i
it there's we can't see any way to do
that and
that sort of extends to all of the
interpretations right the reason we have
so many
that still work is because we don't have
a way to test any of them
yet yet just gotta give it give it some
time
scientists get on it it's not gonna be
us it's gotta be you
right right
now the thing is none of these
interpretations go against what quantum
the math and quantum mechanics says the
math supports them all
right the idea here is that we're trying
to explain
what the math means what do the
probabilities
in quantum mechanics actually mean about
the universe
okay out of all four of these things
determinism
causality locality and realism in my
personal opinion locality is the most
important of the four
you like things being able to interact
with each other right so
it would go in order of importance i
would say
locality causality determinism and then
realism
okay i'm generally okay with that i'm
open to a discussion about the last two
realism versus determinism but i think
locality is more important than realism
and so i am willing to sacrifice realism
to maintain locality
and there are so many times in the
history of physics where
we have like we've come across a
situation
where we we thought locality was broken
only to
discover a few years later that it
wasn't actually broken that we just
didn't understand what was going on
sure right and i i don't think that this
is an exception
so i think locality is maintained okay
on that note do you feel like you have
a deeper understanding of the problems
that quantum physicists face
i do feel like i have a deeper
understanding of the problems i didn't
know where that question was gonna go
and i honestly didn't know if i was
gonna be able to answer yes to it but
that question absolutely yes i can
answer awesome
the goal of this video was to give
people an idea of like why
this this process is so difficult and
like what obstacles we're facing as we
try to answer these questions
sure and what some of the issues are
with the different not just the issues
like some of the good things that they
have going for them and then also
the the things they don't have going for
them right
sure what about you guys did you feel
like you got a decent idea of why this
problem is so hard
let us know in the comments and until
next time remember
it's okay to be a little crazy
right things don't just teleport like
that i mean they can
under some circumstances but it's
okay it's not like the star trek
transporter
well it's not like the star trek
is it